[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hi, Stillwater.
Hello, Karl.
What are you doing?
Tree Pose.
I'm a tree too.
Yes, you are.
In yoga, we do it like this, foot
pressed against the inner thigh, hands pressed together.
Very nice.
Now, breathe in and out slowly.
It's hard.
It does take some practice.
Try putting your hands down here in front of your chest.
That's easier.
Ah.
[LAUGHS]
Are you practicing yoga?
No, we're practicing being trees.
Tree Pose is yoga, Karl.
Oh.
Now, put your leg out and stretch your arms wide.
This is called tipping star.
Why are you all standing on one leg?
Because we're tippy stars.
It's called yoga.
I've done yoga.
Can you do this one?
Very good.
Downward-Facing Dog, Michael.
This pose can recenter our focus.
Now, if we move our bodies like this,
we're in Upward-Facing Dog.
Breathe in.
Breathe out.
Would you like to try Cat-Cow next?
What's a Cat-Cow?
I know that one, cat, cow.
Oh, I get it, cat, cow.
Breathe in.
Breathe out.
Now, follow along with me.
Cobra, breathe in.
Breathe out.
Lunge, breathe in.
Airplane, breathe in.
Breathe out.
Happy Baby, breathe in.
Shavasana, breathe in.
Breathe out.
[MUSIC PLAYING]